[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por marina
colorado este es el espacio de france 24
dedicado al medio ambiente hoy
comenzamos nuestro programa hablando de
biodiversidad y es que el 22 de mayo se
conmemora el día mundial de la
diversidad biológica aunque se celebra
cada año esta vez es diferente en 2021
se definirán las nuevas rutas
ambientales luego de que la pandemia
retrasará las cumbres más importantes
así se espera que se cree el nuevo marco
mundial de diversidad biológica que
podría darse en la cumbre cop15 de
kunming en china en octubre el documento
sería algo similar al acuerdo de parís
pero dedicado a la biodiversidad y esto
no es una tarea fácil pues los objetivos
decenales que se trazaron en 2010 no se
alcanzaron las conocidas metas de haití
eran 20 puntos con tareas concretas en
pro de la biodiversidad esos objetivos
incluían por ejemplo reducir al menos a
la mitad la pérdida de los hábitats
naturales o evitar la extinción después
también se hablaba de incrementar el
dinero dedicado a combatir la pérdida de
biodiversidad pero al finalizar el plan
decenal en 2020 sólo se habían cumplido
parcialmente 6 de las 20 metas sobre
este tema hablamos con luis germán
naranjo él es director de conservación y
gobernanza www.kienyke.com las que las
metas de aichí no se cumplieron
totalmente pues el no cumplimiento o
cumplimiento parcial de las metas de
haití es consecuencia fundamentalmente
de el conflicto de intereses que hay
entre la búsqueda de el desarrollo
económico convencional por parte de los
países
y los compromisos para
y salvaguardar la biodiversidad por otra
parte el apoyo y los recursos que se
dedican a la conservación de
biodiversidad son mucho más limitados
entonces de este conflicto básicamente
se desprende el poco cumplimiento de las
metas ahora que las metas de haití no
están el reto es que la cumbre de
kunming se cree ese nuevo marco sobre
diversidad biológica pero los retos son
más complejos que hace 10 años porque la
pérdida de biodiversidad se ha acelerado
el informe planeta vivo 2020 www.dpz.es
de toda la población animal del mundo y
esto no se revirtió en los últimos 10
años además tres cuartas partes de la
tierra han sido significativamente
alteradas la mayoría de los mares están
contaminados y el 75% del agua dulce se
dedica a la producción agrícola o
ganadera por eso hablar de biodiversidad
no sólo se relaciona con el medio
ambiente sino que también se trata de
temas como la pobreza o la salud de los
humanos
incluso la onu estima que si la pérdida
biológica continúa el ritmo que va esto
se acabará el progreso del 80% de las
metas de los objetivos del desarrollo
sostenible la biodiversidad es la base
de nuestra subsistencia sin
biodiversidad los seres humanos nos
vemos abocados a problemas supremamente
serios la biodiversidad hace posible la
resiliencia de los ecosistemas a
desastres naturales por ejemplo la
presencia de los manglares amortigua y
previene muchos de los daños de la
erosión costera o por ejemplo la
cobertura vegetal de las áreas muy
empinadas previenen avalanchas previene
deslizamientos y
contribuye a que el aprovisionamiento de
agua sea adecuado y racional y por
último la biodiversidad es la base
genética de los alimentos que nosotros
consumimos sin biodiversidad no tenemos
seguridad alimentaria por eso es que es
tan importante proteger los ecosistemas
y las especies que habitan en ellos en
todo el mundo hay diferentes proyectos
para proteger a animales específicos
como el que se adelanta en australia con
el demonio de tasmania en octubre de
la organización aussi arc y varios
grupos conservacionistas llevaron 26 de
estos marsupiales al santuario de
babington tots al norte de sídney y
ahora se ven los resultados esta semana
nacieron siete demonios de tasmania y
aunque no es una cifra grande es muy
representativa porque en la australia
continental este animal se extinguió
hace más de tres mil años
los primeros marsupiales que comenzaron
a vivir en la naturaleza llegaron hace
que en cuatro meses sí y ahora tenemos
nuestras primeras crías en la naturaleza
así
es un hito muy grande hasta ahora el
marsupial habitaba en el estado insular
de tasmania aunque allí su estado
tampoco es el mejor pues este animal
está en peligro de extinción
principalmente por un tipo de cáncer
facial que surgió desde 1996 y que
todavía no tiene cura esto hizo que se
pasara de 150 mil demonios de tasmania
hasta los 25 mil especímenes que se
calcula que existen hoy pero no todos
son buenas noticias esta semana el
icebergs más grande del mundo se
desprendió de la antártida
y es que el recién bloque de hielo fue
llamado a 76 y mide 4 mil 320 kilómetros
cuadrados esto es la mitad de puerto
rico o tan grande como la isla española
de mallorca el bloque empezó a separarse
el 13 de mayo desde la banquisa de ron y
por su gran extensión se convirtió en el
ice ver más grande del mundo después de
que se separó por completo de la
antártida ahora está a la deriva en el
mar de web esta es la más reciente
consecuencia del cambio climático en una
región como la antártida donde la
temperatura aumenta dos veces más rápido
que el promedio mundial y con este dato
me despido recuerden que pueden ver más
información ambiental en france24
france24 puntocom
[Música]